مع وجود سبعة مليارات شخص على وجه الأرض ، من
المدهش أنه لا تزال هناك أركان على
هذا الكوكب لم يمسها
أحد ، لكن رجلًا واحدًا جعلها مهمة حياته
لرؤيتها بغض النظر عن الخطر الذي
قد تجلبه الرحلة إلى مايك ليبيكي لم
يكن أبدًا من يخجل منه.  تحدٍ
أكمل المستكشف السابق في National Geographic لهذا العام
بعثات استكشافية كبرى في جميع القارات السبع
، وهو مستكشف في العصر الحديث يضع
حياته على المحك لتحدي فكرة
قدرة البشر على تحمل
هدفه في البحث عن آخر كوكب على الأرض
أماكن لم يمسها أحد حقًا نشأت في
كاليفورنيا على بعد حوالي 30 ميلاً من حديقة
يوسمايت الوطنية ، مركز الكون
لتسلق أصدقائي ، حدث صديق أخي الأكبر
ليصعدنا لتسلق الصخور
يومًا ما بشكل عشوائي تمامًا لم أكن
أعرف حتى ما هو تسلق الصخور وكان ذلك
غيرت حياتي في ذلك اليوم بمجرد
عودتي إلى المنزل من أول يوم لي في التسلق ،
كنت أشتري حبل التسلق ، وأحذية التسلق ، والتسلق ،
والتسلق ، والتسلق ، والتسلق ، وهذا
كل ما لدي  فكر
في الأمر وتطور ذلك بشكل أساسي إلى العيش في
يوسمايت وتسلق El Capitan و Half
Dome وأعتقد يا إلهي أنني أستطيع أن آخذ
هذا التسلق في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، فقد أخذه شغف بيكي بالمغامرة
حول الكوكب إلى ما يقرب من
100 دولة لكنه ليس كذلك  المحتوى
باتباع الطرق التقليدية ،
تخصصه هو أن يصعد أول
صعود هو في الأساس تسلق طريق أو
الذهاب إلى قمة جبل لم يتسلقها أحد من
أجل الذهاب إلى أجزاء
من الكوكب حقًا لم يزرها أي إنسان
قبل
أن يأخذ حقًا كل فرد.  الشيء الذي
لديك
[موسيقى]
، أعني أن هذه ليست مجرد ارتفاعات أولية ،
فهذه هي أكثر عمليات
النزول والتسلق الأولى تطلبًا على الكوكب ،
ولا توجد إمكانية للإنقاذ ، فنحن نعتمد على أنفسنا
بنسبة 100٪ ولا أبحث عن
خطر  أو الموت ، فأنا أبحث عن
التحدي النهائي والغموض المطلق
لما هو موجود هناك أن المستكشف لديه
الكثير من المسؤوليات ، لا يقتصر الأمر على
الخروج والتسلق لاستكشافه.
إن جعل الناس متحمسين للاهتمام أكثر
بالكوكب والقدرة على مشاركة
هذه القصص حول الأماكن النائية
، فهذه الثقافات البعيدة مع 23
رحلة أخرى في الأعمال من
المحتمل أن يصل libecki إلى هدفه المتمثل في
100 رحلة استكشافية قبل فترة طويلة من
تشخيصي بالوسواس القهري  وهذا
الاضطراب المهووس بتسلق الرحلات الاستكشافية ،
إنه وقود حياتي الذي طالما
فكرت فيه متى سأتوقف عن الذهاب في هذه
الرحلات الاستكشافية ، ومتى سيتوقف الشغف بشكل أساسي ،
وآمل ألا يحدث أبدًا
لأن هذا هو الشغف ،
وهذا ما أحبه.  ما الذي يدفعني
لأعيش حياة حلوة
يا
[موسيقى]